[Music]
hello here are some bad news it seems
like chatbots are the reason why the
future chatbots will not get smarter but
rather dumber than the current ones or
at least this is the worst case scenario
this paper presents and if the future
internet will be flooded by data
generated by large language models and
the internet will remain the source of
training data for future language models
then these future models will degrade a
lot in this video we will discuss what
the problems are with training models on
data from other models How likely it is
that the internet of the future will
contain almost only language model
generated data and which will help us to
assess if and how much this paper
exaggerates in its assumptions which
affects its conclusions
do you ever wonder how the chatbots of
the future can become better than the
existing ones well by letting them
ingest even more high quality data
during training or at least this seems
like the way to do it without any other
Innovation besides that engineering
tricks we are already using and even
with technical Innovation this is
machine learning after all meaning that
lots of good training data is always a
great idea but there is a limit to how
much training data we can get in the
future research is extrapolated from
past Trends how much unlabeled text and
data we can expect on the internet in
the future and conclude that high
quality Text data will be exhausted soon
likely before 2026 and that low quality
text and image data will be exhausted
much later between 2030 and 2050 but
machine learning researchers do not act
like they are much concerned with the
worry that our data production and
storage rate might not keep up with the
appetite of large language models for
data who needs humans to produce data
anyways because nowadays we can have
generative AI that can help us with this
right well let's see researchers lately
did not shy away from training large
language models on data are synthesized
by other models the rationale of
researchers at Stanford when creating
the alpaca model was we may not have the
data collection of open AI but if we
fine-tune meta aislama on data generated
by openai's text DaVinci 003 then we can
make alpaca mimic open AIS model the
koala model from UC Berkeley was trained
on data from shared GPT which is Chrome
extension where users can share their
conversations with chat2pt and
researchers have also used data
generated by models that were already
trained with rhf to stand in for human
demonstrations when training other
models with rhf but this paper says that
there is a danger when recursively
training models so it is a bad idea to
train on data generated by another model
which in turn was trained on data from
another model and so on it sounds an
alarm signal that recursively training
model on the previous model output can
lead to worse and worse models with
every training generation and can lead
to very Stark degradation of the last
generation models at first I thought
that the Assumption and experimental
settings of the paper are exaggerated
and we will discuss in the next part of
the video why they might be less
exaggerated than I initially thought
but first let's see the three
illustrative experiments from the paper
about modern degradation when trained
recursively they are surprisingly simple
but bear with them for a bit first the
authors work with a simple
two-dimensional data set consisting of a
thousand points belonging to two
gaussian distributions they fit a
gaussian mixture model onto the data
which basically tries to find the
parameters of two gaussians that best
cluster the data and from the fitted
model they sample a thousand points and
fit another gaussian mixture model on
this and this goes on and on for 2 000
generations and I know that 2000
Generations seem a bit over the top but
the point here is to see that the bigger
picture of what small degradations in
each generation leads to at each
generation the shape of the original
data is degraded and already a
generation a hundred becomes
unrecognizable a 2000 Generations they
show home that the estimation of the
distribution collapses into this tiny
region with very low spread why like
this and not differently well because
the models of the first generation
strain on data sampled from the early
generation during sampling we see common
events with more probability and the
less common ones with less probability
so because later models see rarer events
less they more and more forget these
rare events of low probabilities the
second reason is that later generations
of models entangle and remix different
facts that were previously learned well
the reason for this is that models
either underfit the data and entangle
different facts or overfit outside the
sample distribution and invent new data
points because there there's no data
that can guide the training so the model
can fit any function outside of the
training distribution and the same
message that we saw clearly in an
interpretable two-dimensional space we
see in the following more complicated
experiments as well the authors train a
variational auto encoder on the mnist
data set for 20 Generations where each
generation trains just on data sampled
from the previous generation so no real
data whatsoever we will discuss later
whether this is exaggerated or not the
authors see that the variational
autoencoder at every generation degraded
in its ability to produce good looking
digits and generation 20 produces all
the same type of mixes of digits so as
previously the models converge to just
one type of data with low variance and
forget the specificities that make up
each individual digit then finally
language models unfortunately the
authors do not pre-train any language
model because they say it's costly but
arguably they did not need to train gpt3
the small gpt2 type model would have
suffice to prove their point instead
they fine-tuned a pre-trained opt
language model of 125 million parameters
on Wiki text 2 in two settings in the
first setting each generation could not
see any original data but just data from
the previous generation and in the
second setting finally they let the
model see some real data at each
generation namely 10 real data and 90
data sampled from the previous
generation and as before but now with
language models the 9th generation
models assigned high probability to
sequences that the original opt model
would have never produced and they
started to talk gibberish which opt
would have never done the setting in
which during training each model had
access to 10 percent real data was
generally better than the setting
without access to real data but now is
this even realistic to conduct
experiments with just 10 percent real
data first when reading the paper Miss
Coffee Bean thought that the paper
bluntly exaggerates their estimations
because come on they do their analysis
and their experiments based on the
assumption that models only have access
to either no human produced data or as
little as 10 percent she thought that
this is a huge acceleration and I'm just
confused why so much of the internet
would be produced by AI in the first
place
in my naive thinking is this only
because we will use AI writing
assistance because I thought that when
writing the interesting stuff is new
information where language models can
only help a bit with the formulation but
not with the coming up of this new idea
and Jan likul was pointing out that the
problem with AI generated content is the
dissemination not the writing the people
using AI generated content would have so
much trouble finding people to read the
AI generated content that they would
leave it be but I must admit I had to
change my mind a bit and now I try to
convince Miss Coffee Bean as well there
are multiple events that are not just
speculations but are happening right now
and maybe you have heard of some of them
yourself for one when Googling whether
there is a country in Africa that starts
with k this thing comes up which is
clearly produced by a language model it
seems like there is at least enough AI
generated content such that search
engines throw that garbage in and
highlighted they and we see that there
are ways of using AIS to produce content
form sites which have successfully
squeezed money from at least 140 Major
Brands how is this possible well because
ads are often placed programmatically
and until ad placement companies such as
Google ads do not do something about
this the problem will not stop
these so-called news websites produce
hundreds of Articles per day for example
by scraping Reddit and letting AI write
something based on the results in one
case they finally got caught when people
on the World of Warcraft subreddit
convinced the bot to publish news about
the release of a character that was
entirely made up and even included the
sentence I just really want some major
bot operated news websites to publish an
article about this but who knows how
many more sites operate like this
and to underline this a new study from
europol estimates that 90 of the
internet will be AI generated by 2026.
what do you think about it because if we
are to believe this then the authors
were not at all too pessimistic when
conducting their experiments on 90 model
generated content in just 10 real data
so what to do in this whole situation on
the one hand we have this paper making
experiments in this worst case scenario
setting of having little to no human
generated data but they did not
experiment with pre-training large
models like church GPT they did only
fine tuning and on the other hand we
have papers that have no troubles
training on model generated data
especially to mimic with smaller models
the capabilities of larger models but
these procedures are to be taken with
care because in the large language model
field where evaluation is extremely hard
it could be and some people also think
that it is these models trained on
synthetic data show great benchmarking
scores and are as good as chat GPT on
the benchmarks because they mimicked its
outputs but that they lack in everything
else and do not cover this huge
application diversity of the models that
have been trained with actual human data
and Miss Coffee Bean is still undecided
whether recursive training is that bad
or really unfixable I think that until
we know it we have one more reason to
tag and Watermark AI generated content
we should just do it for the record so
when training the next generation of AI
models we can decide to easily filter it
out if we don't want the air generated
content so are you worried about AI
generated content that is flooding the
internet we'll see what to think about
this in the comments and we hope to see
you next time
[Music]